hello everyone
and um good morning good afternoon or
good evening wherever you are coming
from
and my name is atukaisen and i'm a
professor of english at stanford
university
and i have the very very happy uh
position of moderating this magnificent
session
let me start off right away by welcoming
you all
but and then also by and giving just a
brief
introductions to the various uh
directors and thus speakers first we
have jennifer divier brody who is
professor in theater and performance
studies at stanford
where she serves as the faculty director
of the center for comparative studies
in race and ethnicity in other words
she's my my colleague
hi hi jennifer stephen pitty
is the director of the center for the
study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
and a professor of history
american studies and ethnicity race and
migration
at yale university hi stephen
c riley snowton is the interim faculty
director
at the center for the study of race
politics and culture
and a professor of english and
literature and gender and sexuality
studies
at the university of chicago
hi trisha rose is chancellor's professor
of africana studies
and the director of the center for the
study of race and ethnicity
in america at brown university hi trisha
so we open with jennifer
to jennifer over to you thank you so
much
otto and uh colleagues here it is indeed
an honor to be part of this collective
and this conference on racial reckoning
i'm speaking to you from the unseated
mewekma ohlone homelands
an acknowledgment that only begins to
reckon with the reparations required to
repair the damage
of centuries of racial capitalism that
calls upon us to exercise
in teresa montoya's words radical
vulnerability
in yesterday's panel colleagues spoke
eloquently about the reorganization of
knowledge power
saphuapua needed to transform the
university
as the recent news about the daughter of
the african family in philadelphia's
move program
whose bones were used without consent
for a lecture involving
my alma mater university of pennsylvania
and princeton university
often known as the south northernmost
institution that sits on the land of the
lana
linai lenape and also where i was born
has shown universities have trafficked
for many centuries throughout the
americas
and in europe
in the bones of
the ancestors and so we're thinking here
about a reckoning of bones
from the americas to auschwitz to
gynecologist marion sims
and that's a shout out to riley snorton
who's written with such moral clarity
about sims's transgression with the
bones
of the dead and the living
and so our bodies and our bones have
been used without consent in the name of
knowledge that benefits
what rod ferguson yesterday talked about
as a professional
exercise in benchmarks indeed all the
panelists yesterday shared their concern
which we're going to continue talking
about today about how to work more
ethically
and equitably with the putative objects
and subjects that the university
hierarchies produce
and sustain and i think that really is
our focus
on critical race studies and its
institutionalization
within larger understandings of
knowledge
so in my nearly 30 years as a professor
having taught at seven universities uh
in many different departments
english african and african american
studies gender and sexuality studies
performance studies
i've often looked to not only other
scholars in critical race studies
which you know was really organized in
the 1990s by a group of critical race
and legal scholars
but i've also looked to artists whose
work intervenes in the restricted
covenants of racial order
in preparing these short remarks i had
too many examples of contemporary
scholars and artists
black and brown those who work for civil
rights feminist art
act up aids anti-war protests the prison
against the prison industrial complex
indigenous rights police violence farm
workers unions disability rights
occupy trans justice anti-nuclear
protests
the demonstrations against the world
trade organization
the bay area's people kitchen collective
i could go on and on
but to choose from to people who are
working
to quote the motto of the people's
kitchen collective here in oakland and i
i
do some work with them to feed the mind
nourish the soul
and fuel a movement and i'm
pointing to them in part not only
because they do amazing work
on recreating for example the free
breakfast
in defendry little bobby hutton park in
homage to the black panthers
but to try to get at this idea of what
kinds of care
or caritas that the university in its
cartesian claims to specific forms of
rational
thought too often elides um
right and so i'm thinking a little bit
of charles mills work here
on the racial contract on the whole sort
of history
that organizes western knowledge that
puts those of us who are working
in the margins around critical race
studies right at
um uh and want to transform that
knowledge
in a slightly uh oppositional or
complicated space these are the
traditional forms of understanding
what counts as thought so these
academics and artists that i've
mentioned
begin to try to break down some of those
barriers between theory and practice and
marxist terms of praxis
um and intervene in university
structures that
institutionalize a hierarchical division
of labor
between scholars and researchers or
artists and practitioners
something that the center where i work
now for comparative studies and race and
ethnicity at stanford
has tried to dismantle by asking
practitioners for example working on
ethics race and technology
to come into the university and teach us
and get us to think differently
about the knowledge that they produce in
their own spaces of work
and similarly in theater performance
studies
we have tried to tenure artists so what
counts as
you know the book or what is tenorable
um
begins to be undone and i'm trying to
talk here a little bit about the
segregation of faculty
not only from students but of uh
different
kinds of valuation of what counts as
the imaginative creative dimension of
scholarship
um and you know again i joined a long
long list where tim spillers has talked
about this in her classic essay on
harold cruz's
the crisis of the negro intellectual um
how is it that we
want to value the different subjects and
different ways of knowing
right in the university that can maybe
go against certain enlightenment
legacies that erase and devalue
embodied work which is concomitant with
the mind body split where disabled
working class
female and racialized others weren't
necessarily seen to be
thinking human subjects and this matters
because
part of the current racial reckoning
asks us to change the quote-unquote face
of the university
and such a shift for me must not only be
quantitative but also
qualitative we must not just change the
color
but also the content of academic culture
redo the syllabi reorganize academic
apartheid to use dwight conquer goods
phrase
at stanford we did just finally hire two
artist scholars
uh young jean lee among them whose play
straight white men was the first
produced by an asian american woman on
broadway and like tony morrison we hope
she'll be the first tenured creative
artist
in our program we can see that also
um uh what happens to the extra diegetic
i'll call it labor that too many of us
scholars of color are asked to do on the
behalf of
changing the face of the university i'm
talking about all of the
uncredited uh uh and unpaid if you will
um labor to diversify the university
right how does that get accounted
for in questions of who is valued and
what is valued as
forms of work under the university
rubric
we can see that a whole scale cultural
economic and political change is
required to begin to achieve racial
justice in the university
in my own work i've spoken about the
difficulty of having
inherited a segregated academy that
makes thinking about historical
connection
connections micah blacks in britain i
think noemie talked about this yesterday
um that made that unintelligible in the
narrow
confines of academic knowledge so again
let us
remember that racial justice cannot be
achieved by numbers or any one metric
alone
as jeff chang says when you choose to
fight you hope it will not only be
merely for greater numbers but rather
for more power
in those numbers that can lead a way to
equity
unquote so this is uh why adrian davis
and her colleagues who just founded a
center
similar to the ones you'll be hearing
about from the other faculty directors
on this
um meeting
called the center for race ethnicity and
equity
so it's e-2 there at washington
university
and this is a new center founded in 2020
and there are a lot now
being founded across the country um so
our centers that you'll hear from today
with my colleagues on the line um we
you know met first as a collective of
directors of such centers and i think
one question we have for the audience
and we want to discuss is
what is really the value of these
centers um
davis notes that without students we
would just be a giant think tank
and i want to just take a moment to give
credit to the student activism that
helped to found
my center 25 years ago through a hunger
strike and that continues with the
founding
of so many of the work on expanding
questions of race and ethnicity whether
that's from
sf state 50 years ago to the present
where we continue to see
new groups i'm getting ready to close my
comments and in doing so i just want to
take a moment from a colleague we met
i think steve was on the line all of us
at university of washington st
louis with adrian davis where chandra
ford who was the founding director of
ucla's center for the study of racism
social justice and health
made the very important point um that
when she established that center
on indigenous people's day she sought to
integrate
critical race studies lens with public
health initiatives
um and though i think most of us here
are in the humanities i want to point to
the really
uh breath that critical race studies can
bring to reorganizing the entire
university and to also bring up a point
chandra
made where she talks about combating
liberal forms of racism
which can be overshadowed when we focus
on the spectacular everyday violence
that we have seen of course really every
day
and especially over the last four years
if not for centuries
um that if we can fail to interrogate
the power differentials that organize
the university that are seemingly benign
but i think no less
pernicious in forms of of racism so
we've seen a lot of um
you know university administrations give
a little statement
around whatever act of heinous and
spectacular violence
occurs but really not necessarily look
to how do we change those
institutions that in which we exist
whether the police
the prison the hospital or the
university
to be sure it appears that universities
across the country are
grappling with this legacies of
displacement of a native
of enslavement and the nefarious forms
of profit
which have brought them into existence
and we can think about ruth simmons the
first black woman president of brown
leading the charge to try to think about
reckoning and recompense
recompense sorry for um enslavement and
indigenous uh uh profits
at the university or even at stanford
we've just taken down the sculpture of
our first president
david starr jordan who was a eugenicist
who took part in the racial betterment
society
but the rema renaming and the removal of
such vexed figures of violence still
leaves us
in our centers vulnerable to
displacement
troubled by remainders and yearning for
greater equity across
differences i hope that these opening
remarks draw that draw from critical
race theory
interdisciplinary studies feminist
studies black queer studies and the like
all my disciplinary formations
help us to sound a call to action to
mobilize compensatory redress
to respond to precarious citizens past
and present
and to reckon in the bones with racial
injustice
thank you thank you very much jennifer
thank you so much
so stephen you go next
thank you so much jennifer thank you for
your leadership you know i
i just admire everything you've done
there so much in recent years and um
as somebody who has been shaped in some
way by the center you run i'm just
grateful for
um your vision that you've brought to
the place in recent years
so greetings everybody from new haven um
the historical and contemporary home of
of many indigenous peoples and nations
including the mohegan
the mashita pequot the eastern pequot
the scatter coat the golden hill pogo
set the niantic the quinnipiac and
others
uh where we in the yale center for the
study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration try to work
mindful of their presence in its many
forms contemporary
in the past um i'm going to speak in a
little bit of a different mode than
jennifer
just um offered and talk a little bit
about the specifics of our center as a
way to get part of this conversation
rolling um i direct the youngest center
represented here on
the panel since we founded uh ritm at
yale in the winter of 2016
and have just completed our fifth
anniversary the other centers
represented here are
longer in the tooth more established
than that uh being established in the
second decade of the 20th century as we
were
gave us that yale the opportunity to
think for a while about what kind of an
academic unit we actually wanted to
create
that institutional contract that rod
ferguson talked about
yesterday and we had some luxury in
building on the great work
already happening at places like
stanford chicago and brown
and being able to alert our
administration as we made the uh the
effort to create a center
that they needed to enable our work in
establishing a race
study center here in order to keep to
keep step
with uh my colleagues on this panel and
uh those their places and so many other
places
so as with every other comparable center
i've ever heard about
yale center uh was a product of
political pressure
as well as hard intellectual work and
compromises with
and by the administration so here's our
story
a small group of faculty members on our
campus including me
first began to meet and develop the idea
of
what became the ritm center in 2007
roughly eight years before ritm was in
fact established
those faculty were in departments like
african american studies american
studies history
women gender and sexuality studies and
our ethnicity race and migration program
no real surprise that those were
represented all of us were faculty of
color our faculty of color
all of us were cross-pointed in multiple
units and had interdisciplinary
interests and struggled to meet the
needs and the expectations of our
various
units we were frustrated by failures
to successfully hire recruit and retain
faculty members working in fields like
latinx studies black studies native and
indigenous studies
and asian american studies we all felt
that students interested in those fields
at yale
were intellectually underserved by our
university in the 21st century
we all felt anger about the paucity of
faculty of color
on our campus generally so in short we
were unhappy
uh we had watched as valued friends and
colleagues were not promoted
or left our campus for other seemingly
more hospitable colleges and
universities
and we felt tired in the 21st century
tokenized on too many
committees trotted out sometimes as
showpieces
when convenient conscious that our
students were not receiving the
education that they wanted and needed
and trapped too often in debates with
our administration that we could not
escape
so that was the situation around
2007-2008
still somewhat familiar today i'm sure
to many people uh in this meeting
and it was the situation that led us to
ask for a research and teaching center
that would both
first dignify studies of race and
intellectual engagements
with core issues in ethnic studies and
related fields
as topics of studies but also as as
prisms and parameters for approaching
these topics
and secondly a place that would provide
resources in space and a hub
perhaps a catalyst to advance the
interests of members of our communities
and serve as a magnet
for attracting and retaining people
interested in race studies
so the second point is important because
we felt fractured
and divided and isolated in separate
departmental spaces on our campus
and we also knew that there were just
far too few of us doing the work
we were then able to actually create the
center in the 2015-2016 academic year
when you undergraduates pushed our
administration
to address campus climate and faculty
hiring
and our undergraduate curriculum we
faculty members
had this center proposal that had been
sitting collecting dust in our offices
from a few years before and we were
already ready to make that
um to make that suggestion so we took
the center proposal to our president and
our provost who approved the general
plan
and but i must underscore what jennifer
said it would not have happened were it
not for students drivable and student
support
in my final minute or two let me just
close uh quickly with a few notes
about our focus in the ritm center and
some of our struggles
just to put these on the table first you
should know that we focus to date more
on graduate students than on
undergraduates on our campus
as a research and teaching center uh
while undergraduates it seems to us
still need much that they're not getting
by comparison
graduate students have had far less
structured support on our campus
as emerging scholars and because we in
the center wanted to shape research
we've therefore put the emphasis uh in
terms of our funding and our programming
more on m.a and phd theses and related
projects major projects
than on the support of undergraduate
classroom exercises
second in ritm uh as at stanford
we've tried to work across the entire
university throughout our professional
schools
as well as in our faculty of arts and
sciences
but also in our university museums and
in our theaters and in other parts of
our institution
this has been rewarding uh but as you
would imagine also challenging
uh and that's worth talking about the
scope and scale
and how to get that right third
we've tried uh in our work to amplify
ongoing work uh
at the university in various departments
and units while also developing new work
that's not
yet able to be amplified because it
doesn't exist yet in
uh more under-resourced areas i'm
thinking for example we've
tried to co-sponsor events and visitors
and
efforts through departments that are
already doing this work but we've also
tried to bring units together that don't
talk to one another or haven't
traditionally done that
and we've tried to focus attention and
resources on topics related to race
indigeneity and transnational
migration like native and indigenous
studies or latinx studies
that have had less pull in established
departments for example there is no
department there there is a department
of afm
so we tried to support fm while also
putting resources in developing
areas that don't have institutional
support elsewhere
fourth we've successfully um
helped to bring undergraduates to yale
as undergraduate students and also
doctoral students to yale into small
departments over the last five years
the undergraduates who we've whom we've
helped to recruit have come in part
through an awards program
that we've run for high school students
around the country who are interested in
rit and topics and doing social justice
work
in their communities and we've been part
of that recruitment process
the graduate students who come to yale
at our encouragement have often come
because we offer them in our center a
home
outside of the smaller department where
they ca
and our home is one in which they can
fully engage topics related to race
in ways that they may not be able to in
their home department and our
center is a place where they can be
assured that they will see more scholars
of color
than they likely will in their small
humanities or social science department
where there are often
far too few of them so that's been a
method of recruitment as well or
we've had some success in recruitment
for that reason fifth
we've been more successful i think i i
in on reflection i think we've been more
successful at gathering
graduate students across units than get
them gathering
faculty across units who don't already
know one another
in fact we've struggled with consistent
faculty participation in our center
partly because faculty remain so tied to
departments
our untenured colleagues of course need
to be present in their tenuring units
our tenured colleagues already serve on
so many committees
so our efforts unfortunately often just
invite more work
from our faculty uh our faculty
colleagues yes
we'd love for you to do that conference
uh just tell us what you want to do well
that's more work
sure we can help with that expense
please fill out this form and send us
your receipt and so forth
more work you know would you be willing
to serve on a prize committee for the
center and so forth and so forth um
sixth
and uh finally we've managed i think to
be somewhat catalytic
across campus in the spaces i've
described uh bringing
funding and what i do think of as some
kind of dignity to subversive efforts
in in various parts of our campus or
perhaps they're better called creative
efforts or
efforts at greater accuracy or something
like that in different departments and
programs so while we may not always
capture the attention of large numbers
of faculty we have tried to be strategic
um in helping faculty who want to do
interesting and important things
uh in ways that aren't being supported
in their units to do that work
in fact we've had some of our greatest
success in supporting
non-ladder track faculty on our campus
who are working on ritm topics we've
been able to provide them some research
funding that they wouldn't get otherwise
we've given them opportunities to share
their research with one another
and we've organized writing groups for
them that are often not available in
their home departments this may sound
like small stuff
but it actually dignifies the work of
people who are otherwise being treated
as
contingent labor all too often on our
campus and elsewhere
i'd say the same with our efforts to
engage
with some other people on campus who may
not be at the top levels of their
institutional hierarchies
some of our most creative curators for
example or artists
scattered around the university who may
not have uh
uh the checkbook that gives them the
full funding that they want but that we
can bring
um some of our funding and some of our
support to help them realize their
vision
particularly visions related to
reckoning which after all is the topic
of our conversation today
so i'm going to stop there and pass it
on to my colleague thanks so much
thank you so much steven so riley
you come next yes thank you etho and
thank you to jennifer and steven for
their brilliant remarks
um it's such a pleasure to be in
conversation with my colleagues
at the center and race consortium and
it's my privilege to work with the
incredible staff
at the center for the study of race
politics and culture tracy matthews
marilyn willis jacqueline gaines and
tierra kilpatrick
as an opening statement i want to
provide some some of the context and a
sense of the day-to-day
of the center's activities as a way to
ground some of the intellectual
political and ethical work
as i see it i also want to acknowledge
that the university of chicago sits on
the tribal homelands of the council of
the three fires
the odawa ojibwe and potawatomi nations
as well as other tribes and as the sixth
largest urban native community in the us
indigenous people continue to practice
their heritage traditions
and care for the land and waterways
the center for the study of race
politics and culture csrpc was
established by my colleague
michael c dawson professor of political
science
in 1996. and from its inception
csrpc has been committed to establishing
and sustaining
a space to center and expand the study
of race and ethnicity
at the university of chicago by
fostering interdisciplinary
transnational and intersectional
research teaching
and public debate so at the center we
understand that race and ethnicity
affect
every idea and interaction and we work
to foster
meaningful dialogues about the myriad
ways race and ethnicity inform our lived
experiences
and scholarship the center is committed
to providing funding and other forms of
support like many of my
colleagues working at other centers for
projects that are initiated by faculty
affiliates graduate students
undergraduates artists and residents and
visiting fellows
and i'm especially proud that this year
in addition to our ongoing artists in
residence program
which we've been doing in collaboration
with arts and public life that we
welcomed our inaugural practitioner
fellows
in conjunction with opposing centers
human rights lab
as part of their fellowship each
practitioner is designing a project that
explores an aspect of the cultural
system
by doing this kind of work we continue
to strengthen community relations
with the south side and chicago as we
continue to act in solidarity
with local national and global struggles
for racial
ethnic economic gender sexual and social
justice
so in addition to providing funding and
other forms of support for scholarship
overseeing an undergraduate major and
minor hosting residencies and visiting
fellows
sponsoring workshops and working groups
which include the reproduction of race
and racial ideology workshop
the race working group which is a
graduate led and graduate only space
the mass incarceration working group
and the race and pedagogy working group
and the slavery and visual cultural
working group
the center supports and sponsors a
number of public programs geared toward
promoting an investigation
of the ties between race ethnicity and
culture often in collaboration with
student groups other campus centers and
academic units
as well as community-based institutions
this
is the day-to-day work of the center and
yet
we are also ethically and more morally
compelled
to be responsive to our current
environment to provide
forums for activists and scholars to
give context and share strategies
for combating racist sexist homophobic
and transphobic injustice and violence
unlike some of the other schools in the
centering race consortium
the university of chicago does not have
a department devoted to the study of
race and ethnicity
however through the commitment through
the committed work of some of csrpc's
faculty affiliates
working within the more than diversity
campaign and in solidarity with years of
organizing from uchicago students
with uchicago united and particularly
ethnic studies now
the grad student union and the black
grad student collective
there has been some progress made on
that front which allows for us
at the center to begin to engage in the
related process
of imagining a renewed center that works
alongside an emergent department
and i'd like to pause here but we'll be
happy to return to some of these
issues later as i think this moment at
the university of chicago
allows us to think about reckoning on a
number of registers
and perhaps also to consider what comes
after
a reckoning thank you
thank you so much riley so uh trisha
you're next thank you otto um thank you
my dear colleagues
members of the crc it's been great
working with you and fantastic hearing
you here and
planning this event thanks for everyone
who come who's come out
on this at least in my part of the
country rainy day
um i'm i'm going to try to focus my
comments
on um a broader set of questions and
problems that
don't entirely always dovetail with my
own center but when they do
i'll i'll certainly emphasize it um and
that has to do with
what i would call the the sort of
consequences of the legacy of the
formation
of race centers and um
you know i and you know
all of the centers represented here have
tremendous faculty support and amazing
work comes out of these places
uh you know graduate student investment
so on and so forth so i'm not in any way
disparaging that level of intellectual
investment but what concerns me is
the degree to which that work uh is is
undermined by the very structures
that force us into the placement that
we're in so i want to talk a bit about
that first
um the formation of the centers
that study race and ethnicity broadly in
the united states
almost always emerge from uh student
protest
first and foremost um and and everyone
here mentioned that at one form or
another
either in the past or in the present
it's like it's no it's
it's an ongoing project but i want to
say a little bit more about what that
student activism is about
because um it often becomes a touchstone
but
it's a very important part of of the
critique
of disciplinary knowledge in the
university students
eventually students of color of various
of types
come to the university only in the last
50 years
and they realize that the structures of
knowledge in fact are not in any way
designed to shed light on the histories
of the groups out of which they come
and that kind of protest is usually
focused specifically on demanding that
the curriculum provide
significant educational um
you know sources for them and in
addition it's a challenge to the role of
universities the social protests
channels of the rural universities in
the given town in a given city
and its role in being a sort of um
not in alignment with social justice
movements in the street in the public
sphere
and so it's an implicit critique about
the role of race in the disciplines
and and that's why this notion of
institutionalizing critical race studies
is such an important part
of the of the framing it's not simply to
study race
because that was actually going on every
once in a while
but in ways that was actually
reproducing the very problems that we're
talking about jennifer talked a bit
about this at the outset
um in terms of anthropology and so on um
an object
um so um i i just want to
really put the work that we're doing in
the context of
disciplines that are sort of
structurally hostile
even with even in the cases when you
have
you know well-meaning faculty members in
those departments i'm not making an
argument against
every academic in a discipline in the
united states
but i'm more saying that i think it's
really important to talk about
the institutional tension that's there
um the
space of centers on race it seems to me
are really developed in the interstices
uh of the university as a whole that
there's a very little space
that is cracked open and we if we
endeavor to
inhabit it to give it life to figure out
what's needed in our particular local
circumstances
um but that process does
results in a number of things that i
think are exceptionally important
one is that it's a it's a it's built in
fragility
and that fragility is registered in lots
of different ways uh it's registered in
terms of funding and support
space uh whether or not centers or in or
interdisciplinary spaces can
be homes for tenure track positions
in all or in part um it's about whether
or not it can be
seen as a valuable and important part of
the university
and its forms of knowledge production
and that matters a lot for whether or
not faculty from other
departments can be involved safely and
professionally um it's understaffed
and then it's often frankly you know
trotted out and this is over and over
again across
50 years trotted out at you know the
crisis of the decade or the prices of
the year
to sort of hold and be the center of
discussion
um now you know i'll admit that brown
i've had
tremendous support for the center during
my tenure but csrea
has been around since the mid 1980s 1986
and for a lot of that time had extremely
limited support
and was in many ways starved of the
necessary resources to do a number of
the things it wanted to do
it however was a very successful uh
incubator for the ethnic studies
concentration at brown and so that's
been a very important
advance that happened before but
you know the level of work that it takes
to
to keep this you know crack open for all
of us
is very significant and it not only
requires the immense
work of you know our colleagues who
donate their time as steve was pointing
out
to various endeavors but it means that
those of us who direct them
aren't simply directing you know in in a
climate of
sort of you know presumed value and
dignity and significance one
one has to perpetually explain the value
and significance and why
even in cases when centers for race are
placed in
campaigns for endowments which is
extremely rare but even in the cases
when that happens
one has to explain over and over again
what one does and why it's
a central relevant issue and why
would any white people want to give
money to this for example which i if i
could tell you how many times i've had
that conversation
so for me this means that the reckoning
is not so much about
more centers and more sort of the
repetition of the structures that we're
in
it's really about a fundamental
challenge to the construction of race
and the marginality of race
to the thinking and the framing of the
vast majority of traditional
disciplinary knowledges
and that can't just be adding on a
section in the curriculum or adding on
one course
it has to be a very significant uh
reframing
of what these disciplines are about
perhaps a dismantling which is what my
colleague matt
gutterill was talking about yesterday um
but i think this reckoning uh can't just
be
at you know sort of hoping students are
going to protest enough to expand
more attention or that um that we'll be
able to
you know have a friendly administration
right which
you know would be lovely and in my case
is but
what you what what i think the reckoning
really has to be about is it is a real
fundamental
infrastructural intellectual challenge
to the whole enterprise
to say that if you think you can do
discipline x
and not fundamentally think about race
gender and sexuality
uh indigeneity and so on as significant
parts of how your discipline was either
shaped or how it's functioning now
then you're not doing the work you need
to do it has to be that level of racial
reckoning in my opinion
otherwise we will be in very much this
same position
25 years from now with a next generation
of brilliant people
who will replace my brilliant colleagues
here and for sure me
and they will say very much the same
thing
maybe with different academic language
um but they'll be in a very similar
position and
and that ultimately is a stabilizing
phenomenon
right so that our fragility our
underfunding and yet our constant
repetition of protest and inclusion and
so on and so it's a dance of repetition
that i think doesn't change the outcomes
in significant ways um and so i just
want to i want to end
with um with a you know a real challenge
that we don't necessarily want to blow
up our centers
right but but there's a sense in which
our
demise has to be part of our plan
in that we have to imagine that
departments
can be so fundamentally changed that we
would be part of that change
rather than keeping this this tension
between uh
margin and center in terms of the
disciplines so i'm going to stop there
because i know
we're been talking a while but i'm
looking forward to our conversation as a
whole thank you very much thank you so
much trisha
and to all the uh panelists
this has been magnificent now i have a
set of questions to ask to open up
debates and and i have the questions
here but i'm going to post one of my own
that i fabricated as i was listening to
you guys and it has to do with
to put it very simply the problem of
proposition making in
interdisciplinary studies because all
these centers
are at heart interdisciplinary now what
do i mean by the problem of proposition
making
i am in an english department now in an
english department and i'm sure that
riley will
will see echoes of his own department
english
at chicago and what i'm going to say uh
shakespearean and what i'm going to say
now
aligns specifically with shakespeare and
medieval studies
a shakespearean to to make a proposition
on shakespeare for it to be salient
in the field of shakespeare studies will
have to master several languages
uh latin and greek among them will also
have to master different discourses you
know medical history
uh you know sometimes even music and so
on
but one of the signature features
of shakespeareans is that they're
etymologists
they like diving into the meaning of
words
in shakespeare there's no serious
experience
who doesn't know something about
etymology for a very simple and
practical reason
the language of shakespeare is over 450
years old
now if you shift from the medieval and
the medievalists are also similar
if you shift from medieval studies and
shakespeare studies
to say postcolonialism my own area our
protocols of proposition making are
different
they are more advocacy oriented they are
more
you know shining a torchlight on
inequality and colonialism and so on and
so forth
our proper protocols of proposition
making are so different
that it is not unusual in english
departments
for shakespeareans and medievalists to
think that
they're in completely different uh
departments
and consent from cesh experience my
question is then this
what uh so this is back to what trisha
said
about the we should contemplate the
demise of
our or the non-existence of our various
centers of ethnic studies what would it
take
for the protocols of proposition making
in anthropology
in sociology in english
in the various disciplines to admit
race as an aspect of proposition making
and this is not simply about looking at
race
because you could look at look at race
and still
not change the way that you make your
propositions
so this is a question about um about
um intellectual paradigms
uh is not merely additive it's not
merely let us talk about race now
but it's about the more so for example
the postcolonial i talk about race
completely differently from how
a shakespearean or even a classicist
that talks about race
because this is completely different
because the genealogies of the idea of
race
in the classics are different what
would you so this is my invitation for
you to
give some some to lend your thoughts to
the problematic of proposition making
in our interdisciplinary
race and equity ccsre
and so on but in relation to how
our protocols of proposition making
might make sense
within the individual disciplines so
this is my question to start with
we can start from
the same order of of uh speaking so
jennifer can
can just briefly and and i do think it's
a related question
you know my father was a social
scientist and he used to say that my
questions began where his
ended in terms of uh being a
quantitative
person um and my greatest
uh i think discussion that we would have
precisely this question um was when he
was writing a long
chapter on galton's theory of g in
psychology
and uh had the good fortune to put in at
least
and of course this was taken up and this
was a racist idea
galton was a eugenicist right and he
said that had he not uh been in
discussions with me
over time that that would have been a
quote-unquote irrelevant detail
to explaining um you know how that
uh term worked and similarly even with
shakespeare studies i know you know the
work of kim hall and we were talking
about this yesterday
um even in terms of of etymology you
know peter stalley ross was actually my
dissertation advisor who was in a
shakespearean
very much interested in etymology but
where that takes you is not just a
classical myth
but to very key terms such as what is a
black amour
yeah and so we are always i think
already uh engaged even the very notion
of an english department
right with you know england uh and the
english language right if you really get
into it in medieval studies this has
come up came up yesterday
geraldine hangs work that really opens
up again to a global world in which race
is uh produced discursively and i think
it was noemi yesterday was talking about
the fact
that you know who is asking the question
uh can sometimes change the very notion
of uh what is important to know which is
kind of what i was trying to say and i
think that it speaks also very much to
everything everyone has said here
um and trish was saying you know that
what would happen right if we
completely change uh what we think a
university is for
whom does it serve what is this about
why are we engaged in this kind of work
and we've seen this with
the increase of the global university
and i think that that's why that term
reckoning
which is also talking about um the
distribution of funds
and sources and value
is so important thank you thank you for
that question thank you
jennifer stephen yeah i this is a great
question thank you
you know there's so much to say on this
um i think i'll just try to
you know keep it relatively simple and
say that you know
i think it is to me i always come back
to words like you know dignity and value
which jennifer and
you know trisha and i think riley and
prop you know everybody
uses very commonly you know i i think to
me it's about
um enfranchising points of view
um dignifying those points of view
allowing formations
uh and understandings um to um to take
center stage
in university-wide and societal um
conversations
but actually minoritize or diminish the
prominence of
kind of narrow uh historically
rooted but narrow kind of ways of
thinking about problems that are very
much departmentalized
you know one one you know i'm fortunate
at yale that we i actually work in a in
a
university that we have certainly have a
lot of problems around
interdisciplinarity and
um recognizing interdisciplinary but we
have some very
wonderful interdisciplinary programs and
they have some they have prominence and
i often say that
you know many for i'm a historian uh and
one of my appointments is in history but
i often say that many of our best
historians on our campus are not in the
history department
um and i'd like to see um our students
in history actually work with them
uh as well even as they're getting their
their degree and their credential in the
department to which they were admitted
i'm thinking mostly of graduate students
here so i think that centers can
you know i think that centers can work
in a lot of different ways i i think
i i'm i'm all for the revolution and
hopefully working for it
um and i think that the idea of the uh
the the the withering away of
departments um
you know is absolutely something to be
anticipated and pushed
toward i also think that we make small
gains in departments by dignifying
people's
work who actually very much identify
with
their discipline and want to see their
future in a discipline in ways that i
may not
uh you know i may not be the thing i
think of as most productive
and yet you know we're talking about the
kind of politics of small members right
there's
relatively few of us and so i want to
see our center for example
you know working with and helping move
forward conversations that may be very
disciplinarily bound
and that i think may not be the
long-term ways in which we want to go
but that actually i think do bring value
because i want that
particular faculty member to prosper in
their local department and i
know that if they're prospering they're
bringing a couple of students along with
them
so i think we can do that work which may
be additive and not
you know um revolutionary alongside
doing the revolutionary work which
is more about um privileging other ways
of knowing
other methodologies um other connections
that you know
are um different um problems of
proposition as
as you were you were you were putting
them and i think that's i think it's the
challenge is to
to be open to doing all those kinds of
work at once and
um so anyway that's where we are i think
on our campus and it leaves us sometimes
unclear about um next steps and
priorities because there is so much work
to do
um but we don't want we don't want to
foreclose uh what may seem
like the more cautious or more
conservative approach
um uh because it's not
it's not radical or revolutionary enough
we want to think about ways to do
all that thank you stephen actually you
just there's a line that you
used which uh you know i was you used to
think a little bit more is
enfranchising different points of view
you said this in your in your in your
response enfranchising
different points of view a whole lot of
weight
can be put to bear on the
the question of how to enfranchise
different points of view
as an aspect of proposition making in
the discipline because it's
it's true in english literary studies
they have historically not been very
open to enfranchising uh minority point
of view
of which there are many even in the
dominant text so the question of
how to enfranchise different points of
view is really important
right please no thanks um and
i was also uh really struck by
that formulation in some ways it also
kind of
underscores how i think about what it
means to do work
at the center which is that we are a
space for
maximalist approaches to race and
ethnicity that there are many ways
through many modes that people are
engaging in these questions uh
critically um to that and and in
in concert i hope uh with uh the
comments that jennifer
and that uh steve have already made i'll
just add that you know
some part of your question is also
making me think a little bit about some
of the fields that i work in
for which the kind of matter of
institutionalization is not settled
um you know to be working in the field
of trans studies
uh it is not really seen as having a
particular
uh way in which a proposition might be
made
and so i'm also deeply you know
interested in or have been hearing
echoed
throughout the the course of the last
two days you know the kind of
provocation
from stewart hall about what it is that
uh
that it for him what cultural studies
would do for example to a discipline
like sociology
which is in some ways it was it was to
to kind of cannibalize it but
in so doing to make it anew and i think
often
um you know sitting and being trained in
interdisciplines
uh you know the work then becomes uh
uh it's obviously always
still rife with power but it's it's also
about a kind of project about legibility
in audiences
i think as as jennifer mentioned as well
who are you talking to
as a kind of uh another note to noemi um
but i really appreciate the question as
an invitation to kind of think along
these these um these ideas
thanks riley at trisha um
i guess i just have two additions to
these wonderful remarks
um uh the first is that um
you know disciplinary boundaries are
somewhat arbitrary
um they have historical formations but
um
sometimes you have different
propositional formations in the same
discipline
and they're they're not necessarily
limited because of it
what that means is that disciplines are
you know
political skirmishes right really uh
they're the result of
winning political spirituals and as such
they shouldn't be treated as gospel
um and they should be understood as
being in
you know transformational formation of
one form or another
so so when you say you know can the
protocols of proposition making
that might come out of a critical race
studies framework
you know what where can it be well it
can be in a lot of places
for the reasons i said right um the
second thing is that you know i
i totally want to um support steve's
initial point which was look you do both
ad
you do all you have to do at this moment
um and you know we've been very
fortunate to recruit some amazing
scholars on race to brown in the last
five to eight years
uh who increased the ranks of what was
already a really amazing group of people
um so you know i wouldn't say well you
know we just got to burn it down we
don't do any higher and don't put
anybody in the discipline
i'm certainly not saying that um but i
just want to illuminate that
when we accept the categories when we
accept the disciplinary
structures and we allow the power that
they hold over resources
right there's no question i don't think
anybody on our panel would say like a
history department is in
in any uh jeopardy of disappearing
anytime soon right like you know not to
pick on you know historians but i could
say a number of disciplines
and that fact is is a really important
part of
the problem and the circumstance that
we're in
so what i'm really asking us to do is be
not so much radical only in action but
in
thinking about knowledge production
so that we don't end up here again and
by here i mean
um that you know amazing work is being
done but
as a number of people mentioned you know
there's fragility around getting tenure
there's fragility about what kind of
work matters there's fragility around
what kinds of arguments you can make
about race and expect
to have the same type of career and all
of those things are
part of the issue that brought our
centers into existence in the first
place
so i just you know you can't have it
both ways we can't have it both ways it
seems to me and i just want to remind us
of that um as we as we as we think of
of how we want our centers to function
going forward
wonderful trisha i like your line
disciplines are products of political
skirmishes
that's a good line you know there's
always you can have it
there's always a food fight happening
no i like this these are all a wonderful
comment
uh now that now i'm going to to go to
the uh prompt questions that i have here
and the one that fascinates me most is
um
actually i'm doctoring one of them which
is
what has been the success
or how do you think you might
operationalize um
placing race and equity studies
on the entire undergraduate curriculum
so
everybody is interested has to do
something about it
do you think this is a it's just a
utopia
or at princeton some years ago
they um they nominated
anthony appears book on cosmopolitanism
that everyone entering uh princeton that
year had to read it
you know now appears say in a theory of
cosmopolitanism
is one what one might describe as a
gentleman's theory of cosmopolitanism
it is not anything that would i think
it doesn't poke anyone in the eye he
himself is such a gentleman
so but that's what the students read and
so they were all
came out feeling completely cosmopolitan
but
not in ways that would unsettle the very
principle
of cosmopolitanism as such so my
question so my question is
how might we you know
persuade our universities to make
race and equity a general concern
across the campus so that's my question
it's so starting with with the jennifer
again
okay and i hope we'll get to lots of
questions too if there's some from the
audience
um i guess i would just say that again
what does it mean to read
because there are i think four books for
the stanford students this year
um one of them i think uh called me by
my name
right uh and they have over the years
had uh
you know neil gerasi tyson's work
and so forth um but
how is that are those texts being read
and interpreted
rejected or valued right
this is then at the heart
of how also i think we need to transform
not just what we teach right
to go back to your example earlier of
sort of shakespeare right you can open
that up
to questions of race and equity um
but but it's it's also how you teach it
and you know
and what that syllabi is what's the
method
um and what ultimately are you trying to
change and is it then also not just
about um how we read or what we read
but in what context and again i'll just
say
you know for for whose benefit because i
think too often even the way those books
are selected
have to do with still the larger problem
um that we have inherited of the
university as a space
a la oxbridge of um educating a liberal
citizen
already citizenry always already um
self-segregated previously before you
know we had
eeoc or ways of diversifying when you
know schools had their quota of
jewish professors or blacks like du bois
were not allowed to teach at university
of pennsylvania
yeah that the very idea of you know the
university
student right is one that i believe is
still
imagined to be ideally
uh you know a a certain
type of person and so that a whole idea
of what is the liberal education for i
mean i don't want to go too better with
that but i think it's relevant right
again whom do we imagine we are serving
and and how those
books would even be interpreted and then
also the relationship between
university and community because often
universities are like their elite pods
elite ports of innovation and some
university department have no
interest in what is happening uh in the
outside world so also the
relationship between what you do and the
communities beyond
that's right three has a lovely
tradition of community engaged
learning and we have students do an
internship but of this particular kind
where they're prepared to think about
questions of
community-based research and solidarity
before they even go
out into the quote-unquote community
spaces
all right so uh is stephen do you have
something i'm sure i can
answer this question quickly i think um
um how
how could we have these conversations
carefully
i mean i think that that's really about
an important principle um
you know expertly i think is another one
they can't be um they can't be had on
camp college and university campuses and
kind of rambly and uh
ways without you know careful thought
and also in ways that are and this is
really important i think
cognizant of the differential ways in
which people enter and experience these
conversations right
i mean for so many of our students um
you know they're um i mean college is so
different from
for most of them what they they grew up
with um and those who we
would uh be want to be very cognizant of
supporting in these conversations can
oftentimes
take these conversations as very
difficult um and very hard
and um and the lack of support of these
conversations for
for people who experience these issues
directly
and disproportionately can be very
challenging so those would be at least
just so without trying to get
too much into the details those would be
at least three principles that i would
want to suggest ought to be
um ought to be guiding any discussion
wonderful
uh riley thanks
and you know i am really just struck by
i think what are some of the great
principles that have been put on the
tape and all i'll
add i think just one more thing which is
really that
um and the kind of conversation
intellectual conversations about race
are happening in places in which they
are also being actively disavowed
and so it's also about uh you know
providing a kind of way of seeing
that what we are doing is engaging in
racialized forms of
thought um that may be absented of
what we see as a kind of legible
understanding of a racialized body
or how race plays out in terms of uh
discourses of race relation
all right trisha and then we'll open it
up too yeah yeah
super super quick um you know i think
the way
i would uh encourage us to do you know a
critical race studies
uh intervention in the curriculum is to
remind our students and
and the disciplines to remind themselves
that
they are formed under a white
supremacist
uh colonialist infrastructure and
ideological framework
all of them and that that's not a sort
of sub-piece of the puzzle off on the
side
it was a fundamental component not the
only one
not even necessarily the super most most
important one
although i think it ranks up there uh
and that
that as a mode of self-interrogation
right you know you have to
be willing to interrogate the self
that's a western you know
philosophical uh framework from socrates
in the first place right you must
interrogate the self in order to to grow
to learn to transform so it wouldn't
just be about
adding courses or readings it's about
asking the disciplines to do
the true in self-interrogation that's
necessary
to understand why race is a central
element in the formation of everything
and the ways in which these ideas that
were not about race on their
explicit terms were all about race and
control and space and who was a problem
and who needed
to be excluded from governance and who
didn't what mattered in the constitution
and what didn't
so on and so forth so the principles
were great we just added black people we
messed up the first time
we added them later no no that's not
what happened so
that's what i think is more important
than anything uh in terms of
you know really um to making the kind of
a change
wonderful treasure wonderful you all so
now the
the questions are we going to megan
are you going to and read them out for
us
or shall i i can i can do that all right
all right please thank you so let me let
me pose this question to all of us
you know we have a question from this
app from an instructor i think
um who's asking a general question about
requirements in their fields
um and if the specifics are about
language requirements
um uh that that are required for the
achievement of a degree
that strike this person as um perhaps
outdated and potentially
um a kind of mechanism for
predetermining
the direction of of of the discipline i
think so
maybe what the question is on the table
is is uh how should people be thinking
about
these things that may be ostensibly race
neutral in a
particular discipline or department that
actually do have the effects
of perpetuating ways of approaching
topics that
either mischaracterize or fail even to
recognize the kind of topics
we're talking about so um i just asked
the questions i'm not going to answer it
i guess i'll turn it
to anyone of you who wants to take that
off
well i guess maybe i'll just say super
quickly that
um when i was in graduate school one of
my colleagues petitioned to have
jamaican creole which she was studying
caribbean lit count for her
quote-unquote foreign language
she herself was actually west indian
and so these questions of again the
scholarly languages i'm not saying don't
know them right but
but they have that tradition um that
trisha just laid out for us so nicely
um again of of what are the languages to
know
those two you know came to us out of a
particular
um hierarchy or where we thought
scholarly thought and in what language
scholarly thought happens
yeah i think the thank you i i think the
um
the matter of language acquisition and
jennifer your comments really got me
here
is that really it's it's supposed to
signify one of the tools that's needed
to get at the thing that you want to get
at
inside of uh the your particular
training and so
you know i also was trained in media
studies a fairly new
kind of 20th century invention of a
discipline
wherein things like knowing code was
a a way to you know to suffice in your
language requirement and so
i think these kinds of questions as as
put it
that are seemingly uh race neutral
but also get at a kind of larger
philosophical orientation of what it
means to be graduate curriculum
in which the case has to be made why
x in the service of what you are aiming
to do
um both in terms of your question but
also in terms of the container of the
program that you happen to be sitting in
while you do your work now
do you want to take a shot at this i
mean you you don't have anything to add
so steve you go ahead too i i don't i
don't please go ahead with your
questions
yeah um well you know i wonder if this
also uh relates to another question that
was asked which is
essentially what students might be doing
um if they're working
in a in a field in a department in a
so-called discipline
in which the issues that we've been
talking about centering race
um you know haven't really made it to
there before any thoughts
for any students in the audience who may
be struggling um with these
you know very specific questions in
their own departmental home whether
those are undergraduates or graduate
students
i actually have a can i jump in yeah you
know at toronto i
run the center for diaspora in
transnational studies a new
so we set it up it's now like 15 years
old
and uh so i was at the university of
toronto before i moved
i jumped around and got to stanford and
this question came up all the time
white diaspora studies and one of the
things i pointed out to my students is
that
every respectable institution these days
has uh a diversity they'll
call it different things they have a
diversity
office and they're interested in
diversity
so that for example banks many banks
have found out
that as new immigrants
arrive and settle new immigrants are
very interested
in putting down roots by buying homes
so every bank has a diversity officer
whose interest is in targeting
marketing products to newly arrived
immigrants and some banks are more
successful than that
but as someone who has done critical
risk studies
can not only shape the direction
of these products but also give the bank
a higher
asset where consciousness on these
things
let me jump to another completely
ridiculous example fifa
the football federation is very much
about they say so themselves so we can
take them on their word
equity the distribution of resources
to various leagues to historically
uh populations and so on what's better
than someone who has done critical race
studies
to go and work at fifa and tell them
that you're looking at the thing
completely wrong
and from my train in other words there
are many
and the more um we produce students
who are savvy and understanding of
critical race studies
and the more impact that they make in
different industries
and so on the more value will be given
to our fields
so this is one answer that i used to
give to my students in the aspiring
transnational studies say they need you
just tell them you are here and they
will hire you
yeah i'm wondering if i could uh jump in
for a second uh
and just ask um some of my colleagues
here a couple of questions um
about what they
imagined would be some important new
areas to move in in terms of their
centers or things they have on tap
for the people who joined us today to
say you know
you know what are we going to do with
the space that we have
maybe it's programming for next year
maybe it's envisioning something five
years down the road maybe it's
uh challenges maybe you know whatever it
is but i think
sort of what what are we going to do
that we're either excited about
that we think is going to change uh the
the sort of landscape of where we are or
what what kinds of things do you wish
you could do and do you just can't see
your way right now but i think it's
important to kind of
you know imagine the future together and
any anyone
jennifer reilly stephen i can jump in i
have
um this is an opportunity to see how
excited i am to be working with
the colleagues here on this uh centering
race consortium
um that was funded by the melon
foundation so one thing i would
say very positively that i think we're
really excited about doing
is looking for ways to partner with
other colleges and universities
to expand the sense of community the
good ideas
um the opportunities to think together
about issues that are just so critical
we all agree are critical
there's just not enough um not enough of
us to go around on any given campus and
we need one another's support
and good ideas uh we need to be able to
create opportunities for
one another we need we need critical
feedback from one another that we may
not
get in our on our home campuses so you
know the chance to work with um
with the colleagues on this call and
with others around you know
uh you know on on these campuses is
really exciting to me
um and we're hoping to be able to to do
this
you know with faculty involved with
students involved with artists residents
involved and so i'm really excited about
that one thing that i'm concerned about
and i don't know if any of the rest of
you
are struggle with this is that our
center has gotten
pulled in on our campus to
institutional efforts related to
diversity equity
uh and belonging right the deib efforts
um and and some ways we want to be there
you know because i
do think that the work the kind of
intellectual work that we do
the kind of uh the credentialing and
amplifying of work in these areas as
critical areas of research and teaching
does translate to questions of climate
it you know there's a relationship
between
ennobling these fields and who gets
hired and who stays
on a given campus so there's reasons why
we want to be involved in
in this work at the same time there are
sets of
challenges i think here when us when
when academics like
like me and i think like all of us um
get pulled into these conversations into
committees about
tone setting on campus you know best
practices on campus
um that are you know not related to the
kind of research and teaching and other
things that i think we're
we're primarily focused on so i'm just
flagging that as an area of
challenge for us um and i didn't know if
anybody else
um had any thoughts about that so i've
given you the positive which is the
consortium that's one thing and then i'm
kind of raising the question of
of how if and how our centers have a
role to play in these broader university
efforts i i don't want to be an hr
specialist for example
right and i feel sometimes like i do get
pulled into that stuff
if and our center does and if we get
pulled into that we're not doing other
important work that we could be doing so
uh if that's of interest we could maybe
somebody wants to comment on that
jennifer or riley anybody well
the the thing is that um one of the
reasons
why stanford i'm i'll have to talk about
stanford jennifer and correct me if i'm
wrong because i'm new i'm only two
two years at stanford why
the recruitment and retention of uh
faculty of color has been a problem is
specifically
because not just because of the tone
stephen what you just mentioned the tone
but also because for some reason then
the numbers don't
they never are able to grow because
people come and they
and then they leave you know so our
being pulled into these things
uh distracting though they might seem
sometimes almost inescapable
but we want to increase the density of
faculty of color
but to to to increase the density and
the numbers
we have to somehow contribute to
creating the environment where
the faculty of color arriving sees
themselves in it
this is especially crucial for
pretending faculty
so senior faculty like me i'm at home
everywhere it doesn't really matter
but for you i can imagine if i had
arrived as
a pre-tenure i would have been scared
for the rest of my seven years
you know before i got tenure at stanford
because
they don't the history of the tenuring
of a faculty of color
let's just sing the english department
it's let let's put it very yeah
diplomatically it's sub-optimal and this
is putting it
diplomatically so in a way you almost
cannot escape
escape it i think you put it in uh
managerial terms and that was my gesture
towards the global university but like
university of chicago um we at stanford
suffer from not having a department for
example of african and african-american
studies before
i too was hired as a full professor over
10 years ago at stanford
i was a full professor in african and
african american studies 100
so the kinds of reach and
interdisciplinarity and centering race
that we've talked about
um was very much a given and um
understood uh and valued and
you know we are like university of
chicago fighting
uh and as you well know autocuz you've
been a wonderful part of that
um not only to have a department and
maybe a department of ethnic studies i
don't know what the landscape will look
like
but also an institute because it's at
stanford that institutes
um have great value
literally in in terms of resources and
scope
and hiring more people so it's not the
same view you know the numbers of black
faculty at stanford have remained
uh statistically flat since the 1980s
um and i think that is in part because
we've invested in fact too much
in junior people which is continuing to
happen who are
brilliant and wonderful uh but don't
necessarily have the wherewithal
to um you know compartmentalize and know
the landscape or understand even
necessarily what a university is about
you know that's a huge transition and
we're not taught in graduate school
to do this kind of dei or dep work
um and so it's again the burdens of
representation that fall too often
on the bodies that always already um
are uh laboring at a certain kind of
personal
expense so we need to do
uh more of that structural change that
all of the
everyone on the call was talking about
to really
make it uh better labor conditions and
really change
the face of the university
um if i could jump in riley unless you
were
about to jump in well go ahead trisha oh
okay i just wanted to
piggyback for a second because i just my
favorite thing about zoom is that you
can like
quickly surf the internet before you say
something
so i want to say that stanford's black
faculty
are two percent of the faculty so let's
just think about the numbers we're
talking about so when we're saying well
they leave it doesn't actually matter
you can't fix the climate with two
percent
so for black women it's one percent oh
great it's one percent well the internet
needs to go catch up that's why i
acknowledged i went to the stanford
website
so that in case it was incorrect i
wasn't going to be held responsible
but that's an unbelievable failure right
in numbers right it's easy for me to say
that because i'm not a staffer
but this is extremely important uh you
know of course is going to be climate
issues i'm sure
when they're calling stephen to say can
you discuss it it's all about
we can't afford to lose any more or
whatever the problem may be
but you know this is a real problem
like we just can't stand around act like
we're we're all doing all this and
everyone
is black isn't doing race work either
necessarily so when you
bring those numbers down you have to
brain bring them down even further
um and i don't think i just want to
comment on steve's really important
point about
diversity work that climate stuff is the
university's job and um there are lots
of talented people who do this for a
living and they need to be invested in
and all the
all the faculty and staff need to be
participating in what to do with that
certainly there's some intellectual work
that overlaps and dovetails with that
and i get called to do the same thing
you're talking about
some of my own research on systemic
racism overlaps
so i can just stay in my research and it
still has a kind of daf effect
but you know that's not what you're
doing you shouldn't be called in there
um um but just one last thing on the
positive because i love steam is
positive negative i have to end with the
positive because my negatives
outweigh the names all the time
my positive is not only that this has
been super exciting for the four schools
to think this way but that
we've really been empowered to create
you know cross
university curricula and cross
university teaching
and i think we should i'm empowered and
inspired
and our grant empowers us to really do
that and i think that's super important
because
not only will that help our various one
to two percent
uh be in community but it will also just
create a kind of collective knowledge
uh and and expand all of our work much
more quickly so
this is you zoom the sort of crisis of
the pandemic
creating a virtual world as the norm and
the context of the grant and the
geniuses who were speaking yesterday and
those of you who are in the audience
here
you know this is a really exciting
moment where we can take this work
make it public make it shared uh and
push forward
let me say something else that's
exciting you know i kind of made this
reference earlier to the kind of
politics of small numbers
um you know this is the this is this is
this is the flip side of you know that
one percent that we're talking about at
stanford or i often say like
i'm one of three mexican american
faculty members i know at yale and i'm
married to the
number two you know and so there's only
one who i'm not married to
um on our campus so anyway so small
numbers right
um but the flip side of that is what we
do know
is that in working with students uh with
colleagues if
we can make differences in their lives
right if we can help to bring that one
extra person
um to our campus or help them to get
that seminar paper done
or get that master's thesis or that
doctoral dissertation dollar keep that
uh keep that colleague who was hired on
our campus but
you know it's considering a move if we
can make a positive addition
to any of those moments in those
people's lives they could these can have
remarkable effects on our fields on the
departments or the
units in which they're working on the
students that
they're that they're working alongside
with whether we're talking about a
student we're talking about
you know uh you know a faculty member
you know um
we work with far more than small numbers
in our centers that's certainly true but
when we succeed
individual by individual by individual i
think you know we
can have um you know kind of really
important multiplying effects
um that you know ought to be recognized
and um
uh so that's one of the things that
makes me happy because when i you know
it's it's
in this work there are moments where you
feel set back by the
larger atmosphere in which we're working
i could have told stories um
you know about that as i know everybody
on this talk could have and yet at the
same time we
are able to hold on to i think um these
experiences
with um with with with small with small
groups of people or even with
individuals that we know
really do have have made a difference
and just looking at the
you know at you jennifer o'reilly and
trisha knowing some of the
faculty you've supported the students
you've supported you know it's amazing
to see the work that you've done with
those people over time and the way in
which
your investment of time um you know your
trust
in their projects the leadership you've
given really has
you know made a really important
difference to to people on your campuses
but also well off your campuses
uh i just saw a question he really sorry
to interrupt that's an important one i
think it's
uh from one of the the the participants
is the consortium open to hbcu
collaborations and this is a question
for you guys
that is the hope we were charged by
mellon with these four institutions
but i think our goal um is to work not
only with hbcus and indigenous colleges
community colleges which
there's a push to make those free now
which would be wonderful
but other kinds of institutions i think
steve mentioned museums
um places of uh where folks are
incarcerated and education is happening
so i think that there is um and that's a
lead-in for tonight's wonderful
connected event to
reginald dwayne betts uh and uh his
interview with e-viewing tonight
but um that we really hope this is the
seed
that's going to grow and connect and we
absolutely
um welcome partnerships and we'll be
actively seeking them out i was going to
say that earlier
when steve was saying what are you
looking forward to and i'm saying
looking forward to working with even
more folk
so riley i sorry to have interrupted you
i thought that was a
an important question to build up so i
interrupted you riley please
no i mean i think i think i um uh
jennifer really answered that and also
gave me another occasion to say that i
hope that you will join us for
uh the csrbc's annual public lecture
which is also the closing
plenary for this uh racial reckonings in
the future of the humanities conference
uh in just about an hour from now so i
hope that many of you will be able to to
come back uh for that but i also was
really
uh just sitting with um you know steve's
um and and i think this is this is
perhaps also
uh inclusive of what does it mean to
think about opening the consortium or
collaborating
um across a whole a whole
host of different institutional sites
which is that you know i was really like
yeah you know often when we talk about
kind of um
uh brief tragedy deficit we think about
it as cumulative and compounding
but we also might want to attend to the
ways that
um there are other kinds of collective
energy that can have a kind of
cumulative effect
and so i really heard that inside of
what i think is the real aim um of
of the work that we've been doing at the
center and race consortium and the real
desire for it as it grows
over the course of the next several
years and hopefully beyond
well last and last remarks
i think we have some two minutes to go
so final remarks uh
30 seconds each starting with fisher
okay you know
a couple of quick points uh ideas really
matter
and this work no matter how marginal it
may appear
can have an outsized effect
and you know i have a tremendous sense
of hope when i look at my students and
my colleagues and all there is
and i just want to push us forward and
see as many obstacles as we need to see
to make as much space as possible and we
hope that we work with many of you in
this
in the audience today to make that
happen in the future
jennifer i put it in the chat already
but i do believe that there is
joy and strength in this kind of
collective work and to know that you're
not the only one
anywhere uh laboring
singularly but rather we are all looking
to do this work and all of it
really does make a difference and matter
so i'm grateful thank you
riley
yeah no before joining uh or getting
into graduate school i was an
organizer and there's so much of what it
means to direct the center where i feel
like i'm drawing on
every available toolkit here precisely
because
there are so many people who rightfully
have a stake
in uh the center's business and activity
and so i'm i'm really
grateful for the opportunity to work
with those folks as well as
to work a collaborative across these
universities
um you know there is a lot of work to be
done
and i think the centers and the crc crc
has been
a great uh site from which to think
about doing the good work that's
available
and stephen finally yeah i just want to
thank everybody i mean we're
if the struggle is long right we all are
running centers
aware that you know we inherit struggles
that's decades old within our on our
campuses and beyond our campuses and in
the broader educational system
and i think we're at an important moment
um as we work together and
collaborate hopefully with people who
are are witnessing and
in the audience today to sort of think
about changing higher education at this
moment i mean we need we have there's a
lot of work to do
to catch up to the realities of the
world to serve the people um that we
want to serve
and to be agents of change in the ways
that um you know our centers but more
broadly our campuses ought to be
um ought to be agents of exchange so
thank you all
so thank you all this has been
magnificent i've learned a lot
thank you very much thank you